you know on the on the timing thing what
the Russian culture has some fun sayings
that we don't have in America that I
always love to kind of like English size
in my head and my dad a mom and grandma
would always say you know man has a plan
and God laughs and and I love that
because I think that's a little bit with
timing right like I sit here every day
and try to figure things out and try to
figure out people's activities and
cultures and where's the market going
and how are people gonna just do it and
and then you know and then something
happens and like you know just real
events
you know like macro bad events macro
good events some kid right now right
this second like literally that Carroll
is sitting in you know in a in a suburb
of London and literally just a second as
I film it's not even gonna say it not
even when you watch it right now as I'm
filming it she invented the next thing
that is gonna change the game and change
my game change it create a situation
where mobile devices are gonna be
different and like just changed it she
just did it and so all the planning all
the concepts all the strategy all the
learning all the experience goes out the
window that's the market that's timing
of it
and that's why it's so important that's
why it's so respected and that's why I
respect it so much and most of all
that's why I think it's practical and
that's not really ultimately gonna be
the thing with me is that I feel I'm
more practical than most people that's
why I think it's practical to respond to
realities instead of trying to guess
them because boy if I had to sit here
right now in New York City and guess
everything that everybody's up to that's
gonna shift the market that I play in
the world that we live in
I'd be crippled and so way too many
people way too many be way
you make decisions without factoring in
that the game is gonna change by the
time you execute your decision and that
is where you get caught and and for me I
play the reverse of that and that's why
I have respect for timing and the
slipperiness it's like catching this
oxygen that it is and so for me that's
why it's practical to respond quickly
instead of trying to predict these
things